[Музика]
окрім повільного вже дев'ять років, вона показує
Нетті Макдак
так кліпер, який потрібно видалити, була дівчина, яка
відповідає, щоб він був низьким, повна
екологічна ефективність, ви повинні дати якомога більше
ключа amatriciana в чаті команди, щоб
зайняти хорошу позицію Lipitor  тут, о, так,
найдешевший Наджібулла в шоломі. О,
Уоллі, хто він такий за його сяйво, поцілунок
ciao a tutti, a perpetual otaku Scola, щоб
зберегти city leaf the cosmos, де OSHA
Prost протистоїть бурильщикам прохолодніше на Міккі,
можливо, Mosley це з лідером тестометром
[музика] час
привіт всім це  на
урок англійської мене звати Наталія яшка давайте
почнемо
і я хотів би сьогодні привітати моїх дорогих
гостей
привіт, надір, як справи, привіт Наталія
я добре дякую дуже дякую, а
що з тобою - channa я добре
дякую дякую  тож давайте розпочнемо наш урок, ми
продовжуємо обговорювати
соціальні мережі в Інтернеті та ведення блогів, сьогодні у нас
буде урок письма, урок письма так,
ми напишемо запис у блозі добре, добре,
давайте, але раніше  що я хотів би
перевірити ваше домашнє завдання, давайте почнемо, тому
ви збираєтеся послухати діалог,
тому що я попросив своїх учнів написати
діалог добре, давайте уявімо, що це
діалог від наших студентів добре, я хочу, щоб ви
послухали і скажіть мені, що  все відбувається
нормально так, що стосується основної
інформації, готово добре, давайте послухаємо, ви
послухаєте з нами, чи можете ви допомогти мені добре,
спершу перейдіть до своїх програм, а потім натисніть
значок галереї.
виберіть фотографію, яку ви
хочете захистити, розріжте її,
написано, що виберіть, як поділитися
фотографією так,
як тільки ви це зробите, ви готові її надіслати,
як це зробити.
допоможи Полі без проблем
тітонька,
так що відбувається в діалозі так
Прісцилла намалювала розрив з'являється біля
Numair телефон телефону все ще
телефон Нік Нік о добре добре так
можливо, номер телефону є так,
які друзі обговорюватимуть питання,
що добре  друже, це не друг, як
ти думаєш, я не знаю, ти не знаєш,
ти не знаєш,
добре, дозволь мені допомогти тобі, так, тітонька тітонька
так, це обережне ім'я або
дуже миле ім'я, яке можна сказати Ананд так
Монті милий, добре, тому тітка
хоче надіслати фотографію, щоб
друзі телефонували правильно, і вона попросила
племінницю чи племінника, схоже,
приємно допомогти їй — тітка,
шотландка-
корейка, не підійшла навшпиньки, прийде це  добре, це добре, ти можеш
так choooo choooo Прісцилла Субраманья
така вперта на Меграхі так, щоб завантажити,
щоб надіслати зображення добре, які
були інструкції, пам'ятай,
дозволь мені допомогти тобі добре, тому перш за все ви
перейдіть до своїх програм на
телефоні так  ви натискаєте піктограму «Галерея»
це невелике зображення
програми, ви вибираєте фотографію, яку
хочете надіслати, вибираєте хорошу або
ту, яку ви хочете надіслати, а потім
вибираєте, як поділитися фотографією маска,
як її надіслати, добре  за номером
телефону або з будь-яким от  її програми,
який тип повідомлення ви хотіли б надіслати
, а потім введіть номер своїх друзів,
і все буде добре, так що я сподіваюся,
що у вас подібний діалог, і тепер
ми рухаємося далі, тому сьогодні ми збираємося написати
запис у блозі, добре  це наше завдання, скажімо,
я збираюся прочитати вам добре,
а потім підкреслюємо ключові слова
основну інформацію, щоб ви щойно
закінчили школу на літо, пишіть
у своєму блозі запис про ваші
плани на літо, зокрема, де і коли ви
плануєте  іди, з ким ти збираєшся,
що ти будеш робити, будь ласка, укажіть одне
від 100 до 120 слів, тому ключова
інформація тут, що важливо для
цього завдання, що ми збираємося робити
з самого початку, так чи йдеться про весна
літо осінь переходить літо  так, по-перше,
ми говоримо про літо і будьте
праві, це не мої плани, перш за все,
що ми збираємося написати запис
і Шарлетка блогера це новини 9 Янка,
але ви не повинні вирішувати так, абсолютно
правильно, тому ми'  не писати emai  l
ми не пишемо текст, ми пишемо
книгу, це інше, добре,
яка важлива інформація, просто
потрохи зараз, чи можете ви мені допомогти, хм,
блондинка замерзла, або Літа, так, так що
літні рослини, хм, що буде
наступним,
мій  нудьга все мм-хм і коли ах
вони остигають так це важливо кизил
є кілька гарно хороших і покажи, що
ти там будеш робити, чанна
Том цього не зробить так абсолютно
корумпований так що в нас плани, що ми
не можемо зробити точно так  Аліто добре,
це композиція, правильно це сфера Навін
міррос бум
добре, давайте перейдемо далі, а тепер його завдання для вас,
будь ласка, дайте відповідь на запитання, щоб у вас було
десять секунд, і вам потрібно було вибрати
правильну відповідь десять секунд, і давайте
перевіримо, щоб у мене були готові відповіді  подивіться
та перевірте, будь ласка, чи це правильно чи ні,
перший не правильний, добре, тому ми
збираємося написати другий, це
правильно, добре, третій це, а перший
це ваш майбутній правильний, так що
буде правильною відповіддю на
перший о  не електронна пошта, блог і так,
і номер три, це плани на літо так,
давайте перевіримо, Браво, це
правильна версія, зараз настав час граматики,
і моє типове запитання до всіх моїх
студентів, як Рама,
ні, тому що важко, так шумно, так,
це дуже важко, але  Я зроблю все
можливе, щоб вам було легко, добре, і
деякі з моїх учнів, які
уважно дивляться уроки і кожен день
знають, що Рама легко погоджується, так,
давайте рухатися далі, тому, оскільки ми почали
говорити про майбутні плани, наші плани на
літо, давайте  обговорюй майбутні часи
добре, тож давайте подивимося на приклад
тут, схоже, піде дощ,
я попрошу, щоб підвезли мене додому
, не хвилюйся, мій брат везе мене
додому, він їде,
тому дві жінки  ми говоримо про майбутнє,
але в той же час ми використовуємо волю
до і навіть теперішнє безперервне
та теперішнє просто, тому все це
можливо для майбутніх планів, давайте обговоримо,
щоб виглядало так, ніби буде дощ, тому
ми бачимо темні хмари, але це  '  поки що не дощ,
так, якщо у нас є темні хмари з
точки зору відсотка, наскільки ми впевнені,
що дощ піде, чи
буде дощ дуже високий, так дуже високий, тому
ми ходили, тому що ми
більш ніж впевнені  на 70 або 80 відсотків
добре, так що не роби з моєю чарівною
сімейною тінню Шибу, добре, я попрошу
, щоб підвезли це на місці,
станція, тому я бачу проблему, яку мені потрібно
швидко вирішити,
я не  не планую нічого на місці
рішення передчуття ліси твоєї Зари,
і для цього я використовую буде добре,
тоді давайте подивимось не хвилюйся, мій
брат везе мене додому, мій брат веде мене,
це не означає, що
він зараз їде  зазвичай ми використовуємо теперішнє
безперервне, коли ситуація, як ми
говоримо, так момент тисячоліття добре, але
коли у нас є щось зафіксоване в
майбутніх фіксованих домовленості, що план
або ідея, ми також можемо використовувати поточний
безперервний, тому що ми вже в
процесі цього, тому мого брата
повертає мене додому  це фіксовані
домовленості, вони вже погодилися, коли
я сказав, що більше шепотом, сер добре,
і він уже в дорозі, чи не вона дісталася туди
добре,
так що з жінками, що це присутнє
безперервно, давайте пройдемося через правила, тому
перш за все ми використовуємо will on  -the-spot
рішення, наприклад, це називається
проблема я закрию вікно або інший
приклад це гаряче чи можете ви мені допомогти я
відкрию вікно Браво,
тоді ми використовуємо will для передбачення
на основі того, що ми думаємо з дієсловами,
наприклад, thing believe hope  або повага та
вирази на кшталт будьте впевнені, бійтеся
приклад я думаю, що ви чудово проведете час
в акваріумі або я можу передбачити, я думаю,
що у вас буде чудовий літній
відпочинок, можливо, ми не знаємо, добре,
і ми використовуємо волю для обіцянок  попередження
надії та пропозиції я зроблю це,
я обіцяю або обіцяю, що я не
запізнюся, батальйон ESPYs новини добре, давайте
перейдемо до планів
і намірів на майбутнє, наприклад, Том
збирається вивчати біологію в університеті цього
вересня, добре
або ми  можу сказати, що я збираюся в Італію цього
літа, ми можемо сказати, чому б і ні, ми не знаємо,
добре, а потім прогноз на основі того, що
ми бачимо, знову немає, це не залежить від того, що
ми думаємо, що ми знаємо, будьте обережні, ви
збираєтеся дотримуватися  драбина, тож якщо ми
бачимо драбину Гордон, так, і це,
наприклад, нестабільне, тому будьте обережні, ви
можете впасти, тоді ми використовуємо теперішній
простий для розкладів і розкладів,
наприклад, поїзд відправляється о 9:00 або
школа починається о пів-  останнє вісім праворуч
або ваше телешоу починається о 9:00.
Це розклад ми використовуємо теперішнє просте
для цього теперішнього безперервного для фіксованих
домовленостей у майбутньому, наприклад,
ви збиралися в поїздку прямо, і ви
вже в процесі, у вас
готові квитки  ви повернули свою валізу,
ви можете сказати в
безперервному поточному, як цей
том ловить літак до Італії
завтра вранці
добре вирази, які можуть допомогти вам для
майбутніх подій завтра наступного тижня або наступного
місяця наступного року через тиждень через місяць
Charis тестує так  скоро  ми не знаємо, що
скоро колись відкриється, означає дев'ять років, я маю на увазі, що
ви можете зробити це найактуальнішим так,
абсолютно правильно, так.
ситуація, тож тепер це завдання
для вас, ми розглядаємо
речення, і я хочу, щоб ви завершили
речення, використовуючи дієслова в
дужках, будь ласка, будьте готові десять секунд, і
ми перевіряємо, що все гаразд,
тому нам потрібно використовувати will, щоб
представити простий презент  безперервно давайте
спробуємо так
номер чотири номер один які плани нашого шлюбу
на неділю давайте подивимось, вівці
приберуть пляж вони допоможуть ні вона
допоможе вона допоможе пляжу
пляж ви згодні так мати витік о
вона збирається мати  тому що у нас є
плани, у нас є плани на неділю, тому
плани виправлено в майбутньому,
тому ми використовуємо, щоб переходити до нормального,
давайте подивимося на номер два,
що група хоче робити, коли він закінчить
школу  l Я думаю, пам'ятаю я думаю, я думаю
, що він отримає роботу
доглядача зоопарку так Браво Тетяна, так що пам'ятай,
я думаю, я думаю, я думаю, я думаю, я вважаю, що
ми використовуємо волю, тому номер три ми збираємося
в музей науки на цих вихідних, добре  тому
ми вже збираємось у ці вихідні я впевнений,
що ви маєте впевнений вигляд на основі
передбачення, так що так, я думаю, я впевнений, так що
пам'ятайте приклад зі сходами
це хордома я впевнений, так, це
як те саме я впевнений  ми
чудово проведемо час, тому що ти збираєшся в
наукову команду наука цікава добре
номер чотири скільки часу буде в
притулку для тварин я обіцяю, що повернуся
це приємно бачити, що це допоможе нам згадати
фантастичне й останнє  один із них Джон
їде з нами,
ми не знаємо, ні, він справді зайнятий.
він
зайнятий, тому його плани на сьогоднішній вечір — працювати,
він повинен закінчити роботу правильно,
тому f  або плануєте перейти до того, скільки
у вас помилок, добре, давайте повернемося
до нашого блок-сторожа, тож це завдання,
давайте подивимося на блок Люсі,
приклад для вас, і я хочу, щоб ви
знайшли важливу інформацію про кімнату Люка
літо так, Робін, там
добре,
добре, тож давайте знайдемо цю інформацію,
куди і коли ви плануєте піти,
подивіться на місіс.  блок минулої п'ятниці так,
куди вона йде,
я був Trillium Australia добре і як
довго вона буде там або коли
вона збирається п'ятого липня так п'ятого липня
добре, хто вона йде з моїм другом
Джекі Джекі так дуже дякую
Сінді  і останній, що вони
збираються робити, що це тут, дякую
, це магніт Парк, добре кенгуру так,
вони будують Френсіс Френсіс, що
таке паркан
шукаю це
так, не можу дочекатися, добре зроблено, тому корисна
мова, яку ми можемо використовувати прямо в блозі,
тому зазвичай, коли ви бачите, скільки
абзаців ми нарахували один три
чотири три, каже спільнота так чотири, у нас
є чотири абзаци, перший є
починаючи блоковий запис,
тому Люсі починає з привіт читачам, що ще
можна використати привіт всім добре о привіт, хлопці,
наприклад, це можливо друже так,
дякую за коментар,
тому ви привітаєте своїх читачів добре дякую за
вашу думку  У моєму останньому записі добре,
то наступний абзац оголошує новини,
впевнені, що у мене є якісь цікаві, або у мене є
якісь чудові новини, і ви даєте
інформацію, про що йдеться, тоді ви,
наприклад, це моя улюблена фраза,
яку ви скажете  ніколи не вгадайте, що трапилося, це
просто Алістер 1t так, ви ніколи не
вгадаєте, що сталося, скажімо разом,
ви ніколи не вгадаєте, що трапилося,
ви ніколи не вгадаєте, що трапилося, скоріше
наступний абзац стосується коментарів
щодо планів, тому ви просто даєте
вказівки, але перед цим  Ви можете сказати, що я
не можу розпочати, я дуже
чекаю цього,
тому ви висловлюєте свої почуття і, нарешті,
запитуєте коментарі, щоб ви ставили питання,
добре, ви хочете, щоб ваші читачі
коментували ваш блог, щоб ви задали вам
запитання  для читачів, чи має хтось
ще якісь плани, тож це залежить від того
, що роблять усі інші, тому
надайте нам інформацію або залиште коментар
нижче, і ви дайте їм завдання, мені було б
цікаво дізнатися, що я буду
зацікавлені знати правильно, і знову ваші
читачі збираються завантажити
інформацію
добре Raviv Dodi так, дуже добре,
це добре, тому давайте рухаємося далі, ми
підкреслили фрази, давайте замінимо
їх мінімально добре
замість привіт читачі ми можемо сказати привіт мої
друзі,
добре або  привіт, хлопці, добре можливо, а що
щодо мене є цікаві новини, як
ми можемо це змінити, вона дякую за вашу
увагу мій останній і спробуйте вступити
сьогодні у мене є нові плани щодо мого
відпочинку Мей Мей
добре, що в кінці я  не можу
дочекатися - я не можу дочекатися, щоб розпочати, як
ми можемо це змінити Я не можу дочекатися, щоб
почати Я хочу почати це так,
і питання, чи є у когось ще
якісь захоплюючі плани, згадана chana
зберегла документ, який був  ось ви
пам'ятаєте, що скажіть мені про свій план
правильно ні ні що аб  з цього я
не можу дочекатися у мене є деякі я перейду
до чудових новин тут я не можу дочекатися, щоб
розпочати у мене є чудові новини, це
правильно, це те саме, ні, добре, так що
це теж має бути  змінився я б так
я не можу дочекатися гарного початку я дуже
чекаю на це так так дивовижне
і питання, яке ви згадали,
будь ласка, скажіть нам більше плану або
що всі інші роблять добре зараз
давайте подивимося на план це
нам буде легко, у нас є
грама-павук, тому запис у блозі спочатку ми починаємо
з привітання читачів, повідомляємо
новини, добре, потім ми продовжуємо надавати
інформацію про плани, куди, коли і з
ким ми збираємося, тож ми описуємо
діяльність і нарешті просимо коментарі
тож давайте знову подивимося на чудовий
приклад, ми виглядаємо так, ніби
з циклом обговорюється кожне слово,
так що вітаємо читачів, оголошуємо
новини, чи є у нас так захоплюючі новини,
надайте інформацію про плани, чи
є у нас це останнє на сьогодні, так, вона збирається
до Австралії  tralia абсолютно права, тому природний
заповідник австралійський п'ятого липня, і
Джекі їде зі мною,
найважливіша інформація тут описує
діяльність, чи є у нас це пам'ятайте, так,
ми будуємо паркани, також ми
збираємося подбати про коал і
кенгуру та останнє  запитаю про
коментарі чи є у нас так, а що щодо
вас, чи у когось ще є якісь цікаві
плани,
дякую, що Яна дивовижно точно
правильно, чи є ще в когось
цікаві плани на літо, тож
ви просто читали павука так,
тепер ваша черга ні, тому ми  збираєтесь
написати це разом, не хвилюйтеся, я допоможу
вам добре, а потім я буду писати
на ґанку, ви можете скопіювати інформацію
на свою сторінку, якщо хочете, і ви
пишете з нами, і ми перевіримо наступний
урок, звичайно, тому  ми пишемо наші
приклади ви пишете свої приклади
за павуком Ґремом добре, так що
ваша черга, давайте першим,
привітаємо читачів, тож дайте мені приклад, як
ми розвиваємось  та читачі у вашому блоці привіт,
хлопці добре, я пишу привіт моїм друзям,
тому привіт, хлопці, ми вітаємо їх і оголошуємо
новини, дякую вам за те, що читаєте так і
коментарі так, дякую за ваші коментарі,
дякую
за ваші коментарі до мого останнього запису  потім
ми оголошуємо новини у мене є чудові новини для
вас добре для вас у мене є чудові новини для
вас потім ми надаємо інформацію про наші
плани з братом режим шоу русев нах
сука тут готує для короля вона новий
Crampton Bravo так що я отримав  чудові новини
для вас ми влаштуємо вечірку, так
добре, ми влаштуємо вечірку, коли все гаразд. Вау,
сподіваюся, в червні я сподіваюся і червні, де
б ви хотіли зустрітися, тому що це
важливий дім так добре, так, так,
я сподіваюся, що в червні буде  ми зустрінемося ми зустрінемося
у Тіани подивіться, це мій жарт
, це не тільки з Тіаною Таня
Таня, тож ти кажеш, що це моє місце, це
моє місце, добре, ми зустрінемося у мене вдома з
моїми друзями з не так, вони чекають
для вас так ні так добре, тому я сподіваюся, що в
червні ми зустрінемося в м  y місце з Надією
добре, і мої друзі та мої друзі добре,
це наступний опис діяльності,
тому що ми будемо робити під час
вечірки мм-хм, так ми будемо добре готувати разом
і танцювати, як гарний голос співачки, я
також маю йти  співати пісні грати в ігри
грати в ігри, можливо, чому не добре, а тепер нам
потрібно закінчити з проханням прокоментувати,
щоб
ви не могли залишити, поки розкажіть, будь ласка,
про свій план
добре, це дуже цікаво для мене так, це
на аркушній стрічці навпроти Себу,
двері виламаються добре, тому дозвольте  я знайду тут добре
все буде добре так не хвилюйся
все буде добре не
хвилюйся, це було б щасливо так, коли я був
у закладі не можна переміщати лікарську їжу,
це шлях, і ми перевіримо, добре, тож
давайте прочитаємо  привіт, хлопці, дякую за ваші
коментарі щодо мого останнього запису. У мене є чудові
новини для вас, ми влаштуємо вечірку, я
сподіваюся, що в червні ми зустрінемося у мене з
Надією, і мої друзі приготують, співати
пісні та грати в ігри, будь ласка, скажіть  мені
про твої плани на це літо
все буде добре не хвилюйся і
будь щасливий
ми забули написати ім'я так сміх
Тіана так так
люблю тебе Тетяна і я теж тебе люблю так і Надя
добре так що час перевірити тебе так що з
часом це трохи чат тести мають
подивіться речення правильне чи ні
автобус прибуває туди о 14:00
так так правильно правильно так, тому що за
розкладом автобус прибуває о 14:00.
зазвичай це приходить до - добре, як щодо
цього Джеріан Боб піде в кіно в
цю п'ятницю ввечері, так що це не
назавжди добре цієї п'ятниці ввечері
дисципліни, і нам потрібно використовувати ви знаєте, що
йдете так, Джеррі і Боб йдуть
в кіно цієї п'ятниці  Увечері
цього понеділка Сем летить до Риму, його літак
вилітає о 20:00  запам'ятати
квитки у мене є квитки я маю
валізу запакований ні ні, це не так, нам
потрібно змінити мухи летіти летіти він летить
так, тому що його літак вилітає о 8:00 ми
він точно збирається твоє домашнє завдання -
написати власний запис, а далі  урок,
ми збираємося його перевірити, тому, на жаль
, йдеться про дякую, час летить
дякую, що-небудь дуже цікавий
урок, ви можете бути впевнені, тому я буду
радий, що ви станете моїми учнями, і
дякую вам за урок до наступного
разу, до побачення
[Музика]
ви можете відчути запах GD звон у вухах, щоб бути спокушеним
немає Roach це частина, яка
зменшується одержувач, який йому потрібно резюме
на Опра Венера Крішна Я бачу потворну
Донателлу ба Баракус сказати, що
Sakawa модульні знання Фуджіти не є
ситуація, коли наші два
Атмосфера Chiquito o GTA дрібниці енергетичний рік
Османія не аудиторія не повинна
служити залиште нам наші знання класу,
відповідні не васила диригент
англіканський єпископ
[Сміх]
[Музика]
ви